الان الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره بان السلطات
الاوكرانيه اعلنت حاله التاهب الجوي في
العاصمه وان صفارات الانذار دوت في
المنطقه وتزامن هذا مع اعلان نائب وزيره
الدفاع الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تحاول
السيطره على بخموت بالكامل بحلول التاسع
من مايو الجاريه وكانت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه قد اعلنت انها بدات هجوما جديدا
بدعم من القوات المحموله جوا للسيطره على
المدينه وان قواتها تواصل تقدم في الجزء
الغربي من باخموتا واكدته وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تدمير جسر في منطقه
شاسوفايارا تستخدمه القوات الاوكرانيه
لارسال التعزيزات الى المدينه
على محور تواصل الوحدات الهجوميه شن
عمليات في الجزء الغربي من مدينه باخمت
مدعومه بوحدات القوات المحموله جوا في
مدينه تشاسو فيار تم تدمير جسر حاولت
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه عبره القيام
بتوريد الذخيره ونقل الاحتياطات الى باخمت
لهذا الاتجاه بلغت الخسائر في صفوف الجيش
الاوكراني 300 من العسكريين والمرتزقه